hello
um my name is brenton bostick and today
i will be talking about
formatting the wolfram language with
some new technology that i've been
working on for the
past year or so um
[Music]
people might have attended my talks
last at the last wolfram technology
conference where i was talking about
parsing and lenting the wolfram language
and this is an extension of that work
and um helping to enhance that work as
well
and i see the three things of uh parsing
and linting and formatting is kind of
all
you know going together very well with
each other so
and this year i'm presenting about
formatting so
there is a new packet
called code formatter that will be
generally available
but just show up so i can show you
quickly an example
um you can
format arbitrary wolfram language code
pro either programmatically with kernel
functions
like i'm showing here or with front-end
functionality by
a user interface by pointing and
clicking that i'm going to show later
and lots of different options for
formatting wolfram language code um
either in wl files or in
notebooks however however you have your
code
you you can now format it in a nice way
so um this relies
on the tree structure
that's being returned by my other paclet
code parser
and what it can do
is yeah return
uh you know this this tree structure
this ast
that can then be used by by other tools
but
more important for formatting it can
return
a concrete syntax tree that
keeps you know white space and
new lines more importantly if i insert a
new line there
you'll see a new line pop up whereas you
know here
abstractly you're just going to get you
know plus one and two
and so with this lower level
functionality
it's possible to build a code formatter
around it where
you can use a pattern-based approach of
strip first stripping out any white
space and new lines that you don't care
about
and then basically just kind of doing a
pattern
you know at a high level it's a replace
of the tree structure with some other
tree structure that involves the white
space and new lines that you want
you know that the formatter gives you
and so
um you can
think a lot's going on under the hood
and you can think of it as
having several passes similar to how a
compiler works
where at the start of the process maybe
there's some
sanitizing of whatever you're giving it
and some taking care of edge cases
and making the the the internal tree
structure maybe more uniform
so that you can work with it easier in
subsequent passes
and then you know you do some more
passes and maybe at the very end
you entered you you do some kind of line
breaking
at the very end and you you might end up
with
several different passes internally and
the end result
is formatted code that you care about so
that's just a
high-level overview um so this will be
this is going to be included in 12-2
which will be
it's in pre-release and you know we're
working on releasing it as we speak
i'm recording this earlier so uh maybe
by the time i'm even
giving this talk uh 12.2 will be
released but you'll be able to do this
in 12 2 and and get the functionality um
also
we are making it available on our paclet
server
and available on github
so you will be able to do
this
to get it from the um
packlet server i already have a local
copy installed but
that's you know you'll do that and it'll
hit the um
the public paklet server and you'll get
that downloaded um
and you can also go to github and
currently it will be it will be joining
the code parser and the code linter
which are already
on github available um for free to check
out and
build locally and play and contribute to
um
if you want and it's getting a lot of
good use there the lender is getting a
lot of good use and i'm hoping the
formatter will
soon in the future also so um
[Music]
yeah so just generally to go over
kind of what people might be expecting
to
use as the functions here um so you can
see that it's removing the white space
and inserting white space where
appropriate
and something more a little bit more
complicated
um i think just x plus one yeah so you
can see
with the set delayed it inserted a new
line and
indented the code so you know it's aware
of indentations and new lines and stuff
like that so
you might be wondering you know it's
only strings that i've seen so far
but you can give files
this is an example file that i've been
playing around with a lot because it's
nice and big and um
you know has lots of opportunities for
formatting uh you can give
code format function a file object and
do the exact same thing i'm gonna cross
my fingers i'm gonna delete this output
very quickly
but um this is a very large file
i'm gonna scroll and like not spend too
much time i'm gonna delete this output
now
but um so formatting files works just
the same as formatting strings
um it doesn't modify the file or
anything there
there will be an export function later
but this is a purely
this is a purely functional type of
functionality so exporting will
will come later and um yeah it deals
if you are worried
the parser and the formatter deal just
fine with syntax errors
but hopefully you know you won't be
running into too many of those as you
um are formatting your code but if there
is one
it can format your code and you know and
everything is fine it's it's
the parser and the format are very
robust in that way so
but hopefully it doesn't have to you
don't have to worry about that too much
hopefully um right
so that's that's largely the kernel
functionality
and i'll go back and explain a little
bit i'll explain some more details later
but
um i wanted to also show you the front
end
functionality so i'm going to open the
dot m file that i was just showing
um in the front end package editor and
you're going to see that there is a new
button in the package editor here called
format cell and um i'm going to let you
guys
figure out what that does um it formats
cells so you can select a cell
i don't even know what a good example
would be i'm just scrolling through
so you you can select a cell bracket and
say format cell
and you can see that it it changed
things i'm going to hit undo
now so that's the original cell
i'm going to hit format cell again so
you can see what the difference is
it's hard to show diffs interactively
like this but you can see that
um you can select all cells
and also do the button and you can see
down in the lower left hand corner it's
it's making progress um and it'll format
all the cells
similar to what i just showed with uh
loading the file there
so um i don't have a d i'm not going to
show like diffing
you know for every single cell but um
but yeah so it formats all the cells
i'm going to hit undo so you know it's
back to the
the original um format and i'm going to
show you
um also there's so there might be more
settings and things that you want to
play around with
and so there's a palette that provides
some more functionality for you to
um manipulate and change
let me just pick some cell
so you're here format selected cell does
the same thing as the button i was just
showing you so
more importantly um there's
a slider here called airiness and
i will just show you and it you see it
set in the middle here
i'm going to crank it all the way to the
left and you'll see
that this the formatting of the cell
kind of
evaporated and kind of turned into uh
freeze-dried kind of
it lost all the new lines and i lost a
lot of white space
um and then if i crank the slider back
it's the original formatting
and if i crank the slider all the way to
the right you'll see that it's now
taking up a lot more space
and so airiness is the name of this
setting
that is adding indentation in new lines
in a way
that is a
setting that you can easily change that
um i mean you know it's it's airiness is
just the term
that is being used where
hopefully adding airiness
might have a sense of increasing
readability
and increasing ease of processing maybe
you know programmatically but whereas
the decreasing airiness
might make it more you know compressed
for
i mean you know we're talking about
there are better ways of compressing
your your code but if you wanted to have
everything on one line
for example you can reduce the airiness
as a setting
and you know and get what you want in in
one nice
continuous you know in in just this like
this one setting that you can change
uh to your taste so
i'm gonna set that back just so it
doesn't get too weird but
um yep so like
there's a specter so i don't even know
if i'm setting it to the the original
value or not but
um and so yeah so you can see that there
are tabs
you can say you know tabs and spaces
we're not uh i'm not i'm not
picking and choosing you know one or the
other you you can change that and
and you can change the tab width as well
so um and then hopefully you'll always
just want to this is just a
the re-parse boxes before formatting is
just kind of a
error handling that you you probably
never need to worry about unless
if you go if you go in
if you so i just unformatted a cell if
you go in and change
this box structure um and you're not
careful it's possible that you can
create syntactically incorrect
code and it the boxes themselves need to
be
you know re-parsed before formatting so
um just as a precaution i've left that's
a check box so
um but don't hopefully you never need it
you know kind of thing
so um but yeah so that's the front end
um ui functionality um nice
easy to use just you know clicking you
can
actually just have your cell cursor you
can just click in the cell
and and do format cell uh you don't have
to select the cell bracket so that's
that's nice and easy
um so yeah yeah yeah so just to get back
there are some options
for the formatter and
they might be what you would expect them
to be
i will just have some simple code here
um
for example you can provide
the string that you want to use for
indentation let me just give you
the other example
um
you can see
i'm providing the string that
is being used for indentation however
you know so you
the very next thing you might want to
try is well i'm already using x
um you know something funny
but it's very important you can go in
internally and
take this checking out but i advise you
not to
if you formatted if you treated the
indentation with
the string of characters qqq you're
changing you're now changing the meaning
of
the code so it's the formatter is very
careful
with preserving semantics and
nothing that you ever format is ever
going to change semantics
so this would be the easiest thing in
the world to actually change the
semantics so
um there there's a check that prevents
you from uh successfully doing that you
can go in and disable this if you
really want to but you have to look for
it i'm not going to show you
so white space and tabs and new lines
and stuff you know go here that
still preserve the the the the semantics
of the code that you gave
so there is
also line width
that is an integer and not a string of
characters
um so
yeah i think the options the the default
is
78 columns because
that is a nice number specified in
rfc for sending internet messages as a
should follow minimum
type of uh default and a lot of other
formatters around
you know 80 characters and stuff may or
may not be including new lines
so um default line width of 78
but just for ease of examples i'm going
to set it to 20.
um and so yep so
i'm just going to have a silly function
here
that's going to line wrap
and yeah so you can see it's it's it's
line wrapping
you know based on on the line which that
you just gave it
whereas if i gave it a bigger one it's
not going to line wrap the same so you
you can
you can play around with that if you
want so i think that's good
and to be clear uh
the paclet the code formatter paclet is
under development
and we'll be adding possibly more
settings in the future but
you know indentation string in line with
are very good
um starting options to play around with
but i envision more
more specific options in in the in the
future
so um
right philosophy
you might be wondering about what the
code formatter
is what its goals are
and one
of its explicit non-goals is to ever
change what expressions look like
in the way that you might think that it
these are equivalent expressions
for example but the formatter
is never going to convert the um the
square bracket version
you know to the to the at sign version
that is preserving semantics you know
this is the same expression but
this isn't formatting this is something
else i don't have a good name for what
this is
right here you might think that it's um
minifying for example
this is minifying in this one case but
in general there are lots of different
ways of writing the same expression
and i the the formatter is not going to
play that game
of you know like using tildes and at
signs and slash slash or anything like
that
um it's going to retain what you gave it
there and so there might be some tool a
different tool in the future
that allows you to more interactively
transform your code and i think you know
that would be fine but
for a formatter it needs to be intuitive
um not you know
the the principle of least surprise is
is what people talk about a lot
so right and so you might
expect so in wolfram language if
statements for example
sometimes they can get very large
people talk about the desire
to ever insert little comments
saying else you know for the for the
else branch
but the formatter is also not going to
be inserting you know comments or
anything crazy like that
some other tool in the future might um
you know doing similar things for
transform
but the formatter is not going to do
anything like that and and similarly
converting
um you know and
you might think that this could format
as
um a you know as that
these are the exact same expressions but
the formatter is not going to do that
some other tool may but this isn't this
isn't what the formatter is going to be
doing
um and then yeah just other examples
like that with
double square brackets things like this
and um
you know rule for example and stuff um
well actually i should say it's not
going to convert
the two character ascii rule to the
wolfram language character the rule long
name rule character
um all all for related reasons so you
know formatting is
it's gonna do one thing and it's gonna
do one thing well so
um yeah and so you might
have different goals for what the
formatter is going to be doing
and one thing that it will be able to do
is fixing format
issue formatting issues and so one
kind of common uh problem that people
have is writing something like this
where
you might have thought that that's going
to be replace all
with a slash dot but that's that's not
how that's not how it's parsed
and you you know this is actually a
division
you know the slash and the dot are not
the same token
so formatting the formatter is going to
fix that for you and show you
um uh you know you know make it
make it more obvious what's what's going
on
the linter can warn you about this but
that's that's a whole separate
conversation
the formatter will fix
these problematic cases
it would have fixed this anyway by
inserting white space but there are
there are other tricky situations that
you can get into into that are just
solved by inserting spaces so you know
the format is going to do that silently
because
you know you there's no saying
reason that you would ever want it to
look like that
instead of with spaces in there so
um the formatter is just going to do
that for you um
[Music]
yeah so and this does belong to the
formatter
versus some other tool so right
so yeah talking about airiness
a little bit more in depth i was going
to
jump to that now
i can't remember if i have promoted this
yep
so this is the default setting
and you can play around with this
programmatically
and i don't think one is actually going
to do oh never
one definitely does do something so um
this is technically correct if not
off-putting because of the levels of
indentation and stuff that are being
manipulated so
i mean actually that looks kind of ugly
so i might fix that up soon but
the idea is that you know new lines are
being added between
groups like square brackets and they're
being added
you know in the set set delayed and
indentation is being added where
appropriate so yeah the indentation
might be a little bit overzealous
in this in this case but so anyway
um but yeah so you can you can play
around with airiness uh programmatically
um similar to how the slider was that i
was showing you in the
in the in the in the palette so
right and so yeah i just wanted to show
you
a few of the stylistic
choices that are made
and so a lot of the control
structures in wolfram language
are formatted especially i'm just going
to make up something
to yeah force it i just want to force it
all on one line or
multiple lines um something like that
so you know if statements are formatted
this way
unless they're deemed simple enough to
stay on one line
so for example if everything was
just symbol symbol symbol then then it
stays on one line so there's kind of
like you know choices going on
um other control structures like
switch and which
you can see you know multiple layers of
indentation
going on here and similar with which
maybe i don't need to show the witch but
um
with syntactic with incorrect
i'm going to give which an extra
argument just to see how it formats it
so yeah i mean it's it's
this isn't how you would write a which
statement it has one extra argument but
it's it's still doing its thing it's
still doing its best
so it still does get formatted
um i think function a lot of the control
structures have special rules you know
for formatting um
especially so
yeah um but
generally it tries to retain
the new lines that you give it
originally
so let's see if i can reproduce this if
you give it
yeah yeah yeah so the white space is
redone
but the new line that you had that you
gave it
is preserved on the assumption that
you want it to be there there might be
more options in the future for
you know completely redo this new this
this expression from scratch ignore all
of my new lines and you know it's just
it's a series of tweaks and finding out
what styles people want
and maybe there'll be a special rule for
lists in the future
where you know their lists themselves
are formatted especially
um when they're just out in the open
like this
and not just you know variable lists or
something like that an argument or in
in module but um but yeah so as it is
it the formatter tries to preserve
the new lines that you gave it as much
as possible
and so if that's ever found to be
wrong in some case please let me know
and uh this is under development and
i'll
be i'll be fixing it shortly so
but yeah so it's a very
general tool that you can use
you can use programmatically you can use
through the front end
and that you can incorporate into your
daily
workflow of authoring code
you know it's possible to you know hook
up to other tools hook up to your
your ide or your you know however you
push your code up to the internet
um pre-commit hooks or whatever
um you know to format your code
beforehand
and um yeah hopefully uh it'll get a lot
of good usage
so the future there are definitely more
things to be adding in the future
um one thing i want to work on is
internal alignment of uh lists and
associations where
you want to align
based on the commas
in the list or the commas in the
association for example
um you want to preserve that formatting
and also in the future working on a
a syntax for comments that you can have
in your code for disabling the formatter
you know let's say you have some table
of values
formatted in some super unique way that
the
formatter is never going to be able to
understand that
you want to preserve you don't want the
formatter to touch
and so a a syntax to just have comments
saying you know don't format this chunk
of code so i'm
you know we're working on that too and
um yeah so there might be more rules
more specific rules in the future um
specific rules for scoping constructs
especially
and different stylistic choices where
there might be a system in the future
where you can choose
i want i want my code to be formatted in
this style
or this other style which
will be a collection of option values
that you can just
apply directly you know the idea of
styles for formatting
uh being explored as well
because uh not everyone's going to agree
on
one one particular style as uh as i've
already been finding out
but um i want to make it usable by by
everyone even if they don't agree on the
particular style going on
so yeah just in the name of um
[Music]
formatting some some kind of formatting
is better than no formatting at all i
think
so um right so yeah so please send me
suggestions for
the future and um come to my code tools
talk
my code tools workshop at two o'clock
where i'm it's just going to be an open
kind of session
um where i can talk about i'll talk
about the parsing and the linting and
the formatting
and taking questions and suggestions
from from everyone watching
so yeah please do that and thank you and
i hope to hear from
everyone in the future thanks